Georgia Republican Senate candidate
Herschel Walker is very much against
abortion abortion is murder abortion is
evil abortion is killing and it appears
as though Herschel Walker paid for a
girlfriend of his
to get an abortion the last 24 hours
have been a historic and historic
implosion for Herschel Walker and you
are not going to believe what is going
on but the real question is always is
are Republican voters so depraved that
they won't even care but we'll get to
that in a moment Herschel Walker is now
being accused and you know accused this
sort of like it's only the word we use
because it makes him such a hypocrite of
paying for a girlfriend's abortion the
woman has receipts and a get well card
that she says Herschel Walker sent to
her here's the article about this from
The Daily Beast and the headline the the
top points are a Herschel Walker says he
wants to completely ban abortion he says
it's murder he says there should be no
exceptions for rape ancestor the life of
the mother a woman who asked not to be
identified told The Daily Beast that
when she and Walker conceived a child
while dating in 2009 he urged her to get
an abortion the woman said she got an
abortion and that Herschel Walker
reimbursed her for it she was able to
support the claims with a 575 receipt
from the abortion clinic a get well card
from Herschel Walker and a bank deposit
receipt including an image of a personal
check from Walker for seven hundred
dollars the reason for the difference
the abortion costs 525 but the check is
for 700 she says it's because she
ballparked the cost to Herschel Walker
after looking up the cost online
The Daily Beast was able to
independently corroborate details of the
claim with a close friend who she told
at the time who took care of her in the
days after the procedure the woman said
Walker who was not married at the time
told her you know it would be more
convenient to terminate the pregnancy if
you believe it's murder do you murder
out of convenience Herschel he said it
was not the right time for him to have a
child it was a feeling she shared but
what she didn't know was that Walker
already had had an out of wedlock child
with another woman earlier that same
year asked if Walker expressed regret
for the decision she said no he didn't
ask why she came forward she points to
Walker's hard-line anti-abortion
position I just can't with the hypocrisy
anymore we all deserve better so listen
I am not against Walker paying for an
abortion assuming he was not coercive it
sounds like he was urging the woman to
have an abortion but I'm primarily
against the disgusting hypocrisy of this
these people and Trump is the same
Trump I mean listen I I'm not aware of
trump paying for anybody's abortion and
pressuring them to get one it would not
be at all a shock if Donald Trump has
sometimes pressured someone to get an
abortion and paid for it but that it's
not something I can speak to right now
but Trump's story about oh I'm so
against abortion so against abortion
since being 68 years old and up until
then I was very much in favor of a
woman's right to choose this is one of
the things that would Doom Herschel
Walker's campaign
if not for the sad fact that many of
these Republicans don't read the news
and if they do they will assume this
story is a lie and if they believe the
story they won't care
here is a montage from Ron filipkowski
of Herschel Walker very powerfully
against abortion
whoa he said he's also said if a baby is
survived in abortion he uh voted to uh
denied a baby Medical Care and high
strength can that be and he's a pastor
and I said thou shall not kill you know
he's uh seemed to be relished on a woman
killing her baby he's a pastor so that's
the reason spending most abortions after
15 weeks what's your stance on you know
I believe in life I'm a Christian I
believe in life and I and it is strange
that my opponent and no one is talking
about that he seemed to be really
excited about a woman killing her baby
what is his term he's not right to have
the doctor and the patient and the
government in the same room and I said
do you not realize that there's a baby
in that room too
the life and I'm not going to apologize
for it and you know and I thank you for
being the states but if I had vote right
now it'll be yes trains because I said
I'm a Christian
right now you say you're a Christian
and they said her so what do you think
of he asked me all these questions I'm
like did I not say I'm a Christian
that means you're supposed to be
pro-life anyway you guys get the picture
so let's see what this does to the
polling of Herschel Walker the good news
is that after Herschel Walker was very
very very slimly leading Rafael Warnock
the last three polls and four of the
last five have Rafael Warnock back ahead
but it is very tight it's within the
margin of error we're talking about
under a one point spread so let's give
this a week and see if this is finally
the nail in the coffin that we've been
hoping for for Herschel Walker's
campaign a guy who has no business
whatsoever being in the Senate but it
gets even better my friends after this
news came out Herschel Walker went on
the Sean Hannity program and then it got
really crazy